since there have been about a hundred
scandal since Donald Trump's
horrifyingly bad response to the
hurricanes in Puerto Rico you might have
sort of forgotten about how truly bad
and tragic Donald Trump's involvement in
that recovery was the Trump
administration was slow to provide aid
they sent Donald Trump to Puerto Rico he
showed up and sort of shot rolls of
paper towels like they were basketballs
at people seemed almost like some kind
of video game forum it was really one of
the worst disaster responses by an
American president in recent history
and it exposed in part among many other
things that it wasn't really clear that
Donald Trump knew Puerto Ricans were US
citizens which was really an
international embarrassment at the time
we have news about this we've now
learned that Donald Trump told a meeting
of Republicans that Puerto Rico received
too much aid compared to states like
Florida and Texas and this is coming up
now because there's a new aid package
that's being discussed which includes
aid for some southern states but
Democrats are saying we need more aid
for Puerto Rico if we're going to sign
on and support this thing we need more
money to be made available to Puerto
Rico which is still not fully recovered
from those hurricanes uh you you may
have completely forgotten about it but
there are parts of Puerto Rico that just
got electricity back in the last couple
of months okay that's about a year and a
half without electricity I don't think
John Donald Trump has ever spent I would
be shocked if Trump spent 24 hours
without electricity in his life given
his situation and Donald Trump
reportedly said behind closed doors that
Puerto Rican Aid is quote way out of
proportion to what Texas and Florida
have gotten this is according to Marco
Rubio and other people in the room one
of the problems Puerto Rico is facing is
a six hundred million dollar food stamp
shortfall and Donald Trump I guess is
okay with funding that but there's a lot
more that needs to be done here
including water systems in Puerto Rico
that needs to be rebuilt making them
resistant to future storms there are
broader infrastructure projects that
need to be carried out some of which
needed to be done before the Hurricanes
some of which
the need for which has been precipitated
by the Hurricanes and I want to just go
back to this issue of citizenship it
really doesn't matter whether Puerto
Ricans are American citizens or not in
terms of the realization that we're
talking about people who are in a bad
situation and have a need but Puerto
Ricans are American citizens and 3,000
of them died in the Hurricanes that's
roughly the same number of people that
died in 9/11 but the reaction from
Donald Trump and quite frankly for many
Republicans strikes me as totally
disconnected from the reality that this
was a domestic catastrophe anytime 3,000
people die it's a tragedy it's a
catastrophe I'm not pretending that it's
in any way objectively worse because
Puerto Ricans are American but if you're
the American president and Americans die
there is more of a direct responsibility
that exists versus people dying in
another situation doesn't make it less
tragic or anything like that when you
consider that Puerto Rico many Puerto
Ricans as I just mentioned just got
electricity back in the last month or
two about a year and a half without
power when you consider that 500 days
without power in the United States is
insane and Donald Trump's reaction is
that he wants to restrict aid to Puerto
Rico further in this new aid package
it's absolutely disgusting and I was
thinking about kind of going back to the
idea of Puerto Rican statehood one of
the upsides to Puerto Rico of being a
state is that it would be significantly
more difficult for Republicans to ignore
them as not really part of the United
States as not really being American if
they were a state and it shouldn't be
that way it's sad that that's the
reality but it's the reality and this is
another sign of just how things have
changed since the bush years and Katrina
the George W Bush administration
response to Hurricane Katrina in
Louisiana was a national disaster I mean
it was it was a national disaster for
George
bush it was on TV for a long time it
continued to cause george w bush
problems well into his presidency trump
almost completely ignored puerto rico
three thousand people died he showed up
and shot some paper towels like
basketballs and it has been a struggle
to keep it in the news and part of it is
of course that on some level donald
trump just doesn't really see puerto
ricans as americans part of it is that
Puerto Rico is not a state part of it is
that Donald Trump just really doesn't
care and can't empathize or sympathize
with what it's like to be in the
situation in which Puerto Ricans found
themselves and continued to find
themselves in but what it leads to in
the end is a president who shows up and
behind closed doors is hearing arguments
about how much aid should go to these
different places and Trump's immediate
reaction after his disgustingly pathetic
response to the Hurricanes in Puerto
Rico is to say you know I think that
Puerto Rico is over-represented in terms
of the funds that they are getting and
he doesn't want to see them get money
that is so desperately needed which
again is part of the United States this
is not foreign aid this is not a debate
over where should foreign aid dollars go
this is the United States and it is
pathetic and utterly utterly
embarrassing today we have a fantastic
program for you we are going to be going
back to a really interesting interview
that I did with Christopher Petrella
some time ago and it relates to two
justice systems which we have been very
acutely reminded of this week in our
coverage of the Donald Trump Attorney
General William bar summary of a summary
of the Moller
investigation I am going to open up the
phone lines after the break at six one
seven eight three zero
4750 and then at the end of the show I'm
going to steal man an argument against
Bernie Sanders this is something a bunch
of people have written to me about
they've said David I like Bernie Sanders
but I want to understand what would be
the best and strongest argument against
Bernie so on the audience question
segment of the show
in the last segment I am going to steal
man what I see is the most legitimate
and strongest criticisms of Bernie
Sanders and I will be very curious to
hear from you as to what you think those
criticisms should be make sure you're
following me on Twitter at D Pakman
follow the david pakman show on twitter
at david pakman show and make sure to
become a member to get instant access to
the bonus show we have a particularly
good one today including a story about
Krispy Kreme donut owners admitting to a
family history of Nazi ties it's an
unusual story but one that I look
forward to talking about with you on the
bonus show but before that we have the
entire rest of the Friday show and I'm
glad you're with us today's program was
made possible in part by a simple habit
an app for iOS Android and web browser
that gives you access to more than 2,000
guided meditations you can try it free
for one week by going to simple habit
calm slash Packman simple habit has
meditations made specifically for
anxiety falling asleep overcoming
procrastination getting focused there's
a meditation for almost anything you are
dealing with in life and there is
constantly new scientific research
emerging about the benefits of
meditating regarding your physical
health your mental well-being your
social life your cognitive performance
it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day the massive
variety of different kinds of
meditations that simple habit offers is
what really sets the app apart and they
just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app you can try it completely free for a
week by going to simple habit calm slash
Pakman I think you'll love it I've put a
link right underneath this video